Hey, what's up?
It's Tetris with Billboard News and I'm chilling with NCT 127.
What's up, guys?
Now, I love I saw online already.
You guys landed at LAX, and your fans were there greeting you,...
...giving you gifts.
How does that feel to get that welcome when you get to town?
It feels great.
I mean, it's been a while.
It's been a long, long time since we came to LA...
...and they were there waiting.
It was very heartwarming.
It matched the weather.
Oh, I like that.
Why do you feel like your return to the U.S....
...is so epic?
You know, we haven't seen our fans in three years,...
...and throughout that time, we did come out with a lot more music,...
...and we just can't wait to show our performances in front of our fans,...
...and it has that much more meaning.
You guys have been touring already  before you came to the States.
Tell me about the tour so far and what's been your favorite part.
So far, the tour is great as it used to be, and since the quarantine,...
...it's been a long time meeting our fans face to face.
But throughout the tour, we're meeting our fans all around the world.
So we're so excited just doing the tour and meeting our fans.